In material design, we imagine UI's to
be composed of pieces of digital paper,
which we call surfaces.
Now these surfaces have tangible
attributes to imply real world
behaviors, but they aren't limited
like their real world equivalents.
Everything on the screen lives in one
of these surfaces, including all texts,
icons, photos, buttons,
any UI element, really.
Now, these surfaces have
a tiny amount of physicality,
just enough to show that one
thing is distinct from another.
And how they sit
relative to one another.
This taps into our instinctive
ability to quickly recognize objects.
There's no need to take the metaphor
too far, and use real world textures,
sheens, spectral highlights, and so on.
Just the smallest set of real world cues
are enough to express a lot of meaning.
Surfaces also exist in 3D space,
we have varying widths and heights, and
at different elevations.
These surfaces are arranged in front
of and behind one another, and
cast shadows on lower surfaces.
So here we can see as the fab
raises up in elevation,
it casts a more diffused shadow.
Let's take a small detour and
really focus in about how and
why shadows get cast by surfaces.
In general, objects that are closer to
us command more of our visual attention.
And we can tell which objects
are closer based on their size and
how they cover and cast shadows.
On the things that are behind them.
So we can use depth as a queue in our UI
to direct attention to
important elements.
So how do we use these
concepts on a 2D screen?
We use the shadows to convey a surface's
elevation relative to other surfaces.
Surfaces nearer to you
will cast a larger shadow.
There's a lot of complicated maths
behind how to draw these shadows
correctly.
But luckily, on Android,
we only have to edit a bit of code
to have the shadows drawn
dynamically for us.